All right, so we're doing well, but sometimes new information is like drinking from a fire hose, right?
I realize that, but remember, this is braid-based therapy. Okay? This is stretching your braid.
So, a little bit about that. That's the best thing you can do. I'll say switch it around. The worst thing you can do is stop learning.
Absolutely. Absolute worst thing you can do. I'm going to retire. I don't have to think about anything else. Okay, good luck with that.
You have to constantly be learning. Constantly be studying. Constantly learning new things.
You, the only person that can take charge of your braid with the toxicity in the world today that you can't even get rid of,
that is the biggest thing that we're dealing with dementia issues. Also, there's Parkinson's and other dementia.
So, you really have to make sure that you're working on that on a daily basis.
So, I applaud you to come in from coming to this conference. It's been, I think it's helpful, and I think it just helps you.
Even if you don't remember a word that I say, your braid just got stretched, and when you go home, if you go on our website and watch some of the videos, you go,
oh yeah, I remember that. I remember that. You just do it over and over again, and you start to become an expert.
To be honest with you, everything that I shared with you today, literally, you could be a whole bunch of wonderful, functional medical practitioners sitting in this room, and it would still be all due to you.
So, it's not super well-known information yet. So, you are at the cutting edge. So, if you go into your doctor and say,
well yeah, I think I might have some gandwood defects. So, I have to stay away from glutamate, the most likely, here she's going to go, your nuts, get out of here.
So, you should use this new knowledge wisely, right?
Okay, so, I want to kind of open up to some questions. Honestly, I didn't even know I had the rest this time.
So, this is great. Hopefully this has been helpful. Are you learning something?
So, I do apologize. There's been some people that came here that wanted to know about cancer, and I didn't get into anything specifically about cancer.
And always, this is a little, you know, g-defect that I have. Whatever I speak to doctors or groups or patients or anything, I never like to repeat myself.
And when I feel like I'm repeating myself, I feel like I'm cheating somebody. Do you know what I mean? Like, oh, I already sent that last year.
Right? I know I sent that two years ago. So, I don't ever want to say it again, but I know that really makes any sense whatsoever because not everybody was here last year in the world and you never realize everything I said.
So, I apologize for that. But so, let's talk a little bit about who has cancer or had cancer or wants to have cancer.
So, when we talk about cancer in our office, it really, it's the same thing with any chronic patient, any patient we take on our larger plans, there's four pieces that I call pillars that we have to deal with.
So, there's four pillars. So, it's easiest to explain with cancer. The first pillar is what is the cause and how are we going to get rid of that?
So, when you're dealing with cancer, there's always a cause. So, for a standard oncology approach, that is completely ignored.
Unless you donate to your body of science after you're dying of cancer, and that's what they're doing with the study on.
For instance, H. Pylori, which is a grand negative bacteria in the same family as Lyme Borrelia, is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide according to the World Health Organization based upon numerous studies on the causes of stomach cancer.
That we're funded by some pharmaceutical company wanting to kill H. Pylori, probably. But otherwise, it's a completely ignored. They don't even steal.
If you had come into the oncologist with stomach cancer and you came in and said, Dr, here's a paper from the World Health Organization that says the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide is H. Pylori infection. Are you going to treat my H. Pylori infection?
He probably, again, either throw you out of the office or he'll say, yeah, we'll look at that. And here's the chemotherapy that we're going to do.
Still, even having that knowledge, they still don't treat the cause. Do you understand? To me, it makes no sense. If you have a cause of cancer, there is a reason why to understand what cancer is. Cancer is a normal cell that is for some reason, cause is not going through normal program cell death apoptosis.
It is in a state of rapid replication, which in itself is a state of an issue with methylation. So the idea of how a cell replicates, a cell every cell in your body will replicate a new cell and the mother cell will die.
And that is how your body survives. You slump off skin cells because you replicated new skin cells and the other skin cells died and they slucked off.
That's called apoptosis. That's a neuro program cell death. If a cell doesn't go through apoptosis, normal program cell death.
And it, for some reason, is in a hypo methylation of the DNA replication cycle, it will be in a state of hyper replication. That is by definition cancer. That's what cancer is.
Yes, cells not dying and hyper replicated. Why? There's an issue. There's a genetic issue. There's a toxicity issue. There's some chemical toxicity. There's some infection. There's some something is going on. We need to address that piece.
So that's pillar number one. What's the cause and how are we going to get rid of it? And I believe you can find out that answer.
Number two is what are we going to use from a nutraceutical standpoint? So I have an alternative cancer doctor. I don't use chemotherapy.
So what are we going to use from a alternative chemotherapy? A nutraceutical? Something from a nutritional standpoint that's going to specifically affect the cancer itself. There's lots of things out there.
Are we going to use rick Simpson oil that somebody brought up today before? THC? Are we going to use Hoxy? Are we going to use Laya Trill? Are we going to use...
There's 20, 30 different possible nutraceutical cancer killers out there. So we test for what that is. What are we going to use specifically? That's the second pillar. What are we going to use for the patient?
So I test using a specialized form of kinesiology. Thirdly, I use the rife with every cancer patient. What frequencies are we going to use?
So we decide what frequencies we're going to use for that patient based upon scanning them.
And we use the ones that develop that skater that I think Mike has out here with the electron that you connect to the K-27 point.
And we scan for frequencies. That's one way. I determine what frequencies we're going to use. There's no frequencies for that specific cancer. We're going to use that.
We're going to use frequencies to support adjacent organs and support detoxification pathways and support the kidneys and the gut, etc.
And we're going to use some other frequencies depending on what I also want to... whatever I tested is the cause for that cancer. We're going to help support that.
And some other things that I want to put in the program.
So I personally write every single person's program and I write night programs. So they're running the programs while they're sleeping.
So I personally... it's just my philosophy. I don't want my patients right feet all day long. I want them living. What good is it? Why am I going to stay alive for another five years with those cancer?
I have to sit in front of the right for she don't know. I'm not living. I want them living. I want them to go get their job back. I want them to be a productive member of society.
So that you can write. You can do most of your treatment at night while you're sleeping. You've got to sleep any home.
Yes. Do I have a generalized favorite detox program I do at night? No.
Sorry. I don't believe in protocols. So I want to build a protocol around the patient in their needs.
So that's the third piece. We're using the right feet. The fourth piece is a hot pod, especially for cancer patients. We're going to look at their genetics.
We're going to look at what diet we're going to put up. Do they need to be on a low botanian diet, a low glutinous diet, a glutinous diet, a low sugar diet?
So what do we need to do with that person? Is diet even driving the cancer at all? Sometimes it's not.
What do we need to do to support the liver or the gut? We don't know all the stuff that we talked about today. It just goes on and on.
Are we going to do coffee? Are we going to do this?
There's an emotional spiritual side. We need to support that too. You can't get out of this terror in your mind. You're never going to get better.
We have to balance the sympathetic and parasympathetics. That's the other side of your nervous system, your autonomic nervous system that controls all organ function.
So for persons that are sympathetic, dominant state, we have to pull that down and balance that and stimulate vagal nerve function.
So there's a lot of different pieces that are fourth pillar. But those are the four pillars that we go through.
It takes two days in our office to really sludge through most of that.
Patient goes home with a right machine. They start using it every night. They go home with a three-rowing binder with their program and their protocol and they're following that.
And then as we get the gene information back, we tweak it and we add that and we just keep tweaking their program.
And if the patient continues to do well, it was supposed to be dead three months ago.
They're doing great. No, six months later, 12 months later, we just continue on. And that's our goal.
So I don't believe I cure cancer. I don't believe that anybody cures cancer.
But I do believe that you can manage it and turn it into a chronic manageable disorder that you can continue to live long after you were not supposed to be alive.
So that's our goal.
So that's what we do for patients that come in our office.
Live, it's very similar.
Live, you have to deal with some other things that you don't have to do with cancer.
Live is more difficult to deal with than cancer.
And I've said multiple times. And why live patients give me an enemy.
But I'd rather have a stage four cancer patient walk in the door than a chronic live patient.
Because they're easier to fix.
You're what?
Easier to fix.
So with live, you have to deal with a lot of inflammation of the brain.
And that's when you have to build brain pathways.
And that's where you know, using home brain-based therapy.
And I have a home brain-based therapy manual.
And we send home with patients.
And sometimes it'll feed back you.
And if that we send home with patients.
All right.
No.
So a Bikes program uses brain and treatment.
So let's touch on that a little bit.
What is brain and treatment?
You're brain from a electrical perspective.
Fires at different parts.
That is cycles per second.
So when I'm going to fall asleep, I have to be noted about four to five hertz.
That's an alpha wave.
When I'm like all excited at a similar, or listening to Dr. Cutters,
wait a second, everybody's really at four hertz.
You're at about 25 hertz.
A beta wave, a high beta wave, is about 28 hertz.
That's when you're really concentrated.
You're really excited.
You're playing basketball.
You're really concentrated in a game.
You're excited.
You're at a very high frequency.
And about 28 hertz.
Do you realize you're watching this screen all day?
This is brain and treatment at 60 hertz.
Screens.
All screens.
Television screens.
Telephone screens.
High-pad screens.
Every computer screen type thing is focusing at 60 hertz.
You are trading your brain at 60 hertz.
So this is another thing we have an 80-80-80-HD child.
They can't use screens.
We limit their screen time.
You can get blocking glasses.
Dark amber sunglasses that will help block some of that.
Note if it's perfect.
You're going to limit screen time.
This is one of our problems in society.
Is it a chemical issue?
Yes.
Is it a disciplined issue?
Maybe.
Is there other, you know, toxicity issues,
vaccine issues, all these things?
Kids are going outside playing anymore.
They're not playing in the dirt, building their immune system.
Grouting themselves.
They're in front of screens, watching computers,
playing video games, looking for Pokemon characters.
Is that 60 hertz because of the...
That's just how it's made.
They're all made that way.
Yep.
You are trading your brain at 60 hertz,
and I think you're going to drop down to 4 hertz and go to sleep.
This again adds to early dementia.
They're very excited to worry until your brain.
Your feedback is different than brain entertainment.
Your feedback, you're specifically connecting leads to whatever part of the brain
that you're trying to fire connected to a piece of equipment,
connected to a computer.
Yes, you're getting screen time,
but you're really doing 20 minutes of it.
And you're actually turning that movie on and off with your brain.
So if I'm connected to my...
my FP1, FP2 right here,
that's firing my prefrontal cortex.
So if I have prefrontal cortex issues,
I can purposely trade my prefrontal cortex.
Or if I have chronic pain issues,
I can purposely trade my parietal lobe to help.
Any other questions?
We had only a couple of minutes left.
Fact of yes.
Oh boy.
No.
That was similar two years ago with it.
Okay.
So I am a section of my website on autoimmune.
And my phase three life is autoimmune life.
And I have very different theory
than most autoimmune doctors out there.
So you should read my book, Help My Body's Killing Me.
I would not download another Amazon.
I mean, would not buy it off Amazon,
I would download it off our website,
because I have updated it multiple times
and I never reprinted it.
And if this information about the brain helps you,
I would read the download three phases of live book.
If you really want to get into the brain,
download about your crazy.
That is much more meat of the brain
and how the neural pathways work.
But if you want a little bit more meat of that subject,
I would read that.
Help My Body's Killing Me will really help you understand
by philosophy of autoimmune disease.
Why it's so prevalent and how you have to treat it
very differently than it's being treated today.
All right.
And hopefully this was helpful.
How long you can do the brain and trailer?
That is a question for your doctor.
I can't tell you that because it's better
than what you're treating your brain at,
what frequency you're treating,
you're doing the treatment.
So if you're doing the alpha and treatment
for herds or something like that,
and you're falling asleep,
and you don't want to be falling asleep,
then you're probably doing too much.
So it really depends on what frequency you're treating.
But all the brain and treatment programming,
and that's a question for this gentleman right here,
are at the normal brain function frequency.
So it's either alpha, beta, or theta,
or whatever they're trying to train.
So that's a good question.
It's a good segue for our next speaker.
Thank you.
Some of you had some additional questions
about the brain and treatment
and the eye-resonant system in the app.
So as Dr. Connors was saying,
with brain and treatment,
what we're really trying to do is we're trying
to adjust brain wave patterns
because your brain has gotten into a habit
of operating at a different frequency
from what it should be operating at.
So really what new, if you've got the question
in your mind, should I be using brain and treatment?
Or should I be using the eye-resonant system?
Or should I be using the right system?
The answer is, for brain and treatment,
is the brain the primary target?
Is it the primary cause of the dysfunction?
If the answer to that is no,
you shouldn't be doing the brain and treatment.
Use something else.
If the brain is a symptom of the problem,
address the primary target.
That's the simplest explanation.
Again, your doctor can help you to understand
what exactly it is if it's the primary issue
or if it's just a symptom of the real issue.
The eye-resonant system.
People were asking,
so exactly how does that work?
Joel had asked earlier about phase
and the good news is that those signals are off phase
from one another between the left and the right
by 1, 1500,000s of a second.
So there's just about the same amount of phase
as there is when you're using the F117.
So we do have that extra punch.
But the reason that we said to keep the eye-resonant system
the straps on the inside of your wrist
so that it could directly address the nervous system
is because that's what those frequencies are intended to do.
Those frequencies are not going to kill pathogens
or parasites.
So if, for example,
one of those protocols is for Lyme disease.
If you're not doing anything on your F117,
on your true-if-instruments for Lyme disease,
if you're not doing anything else,
verbally, that's telling your system to attack the Lyme disease
when you use that frequency,
your nervous system is going to say,
what's that?
So it's not going to do anything.
Rather, if you are using your F117
and that's a frequency,
that particular frequency that's used in the eye-resonant system
is something that's in all of the Lyme frequency sets,
then your nervous system already recognizes
what that frequency is for.
So you're stimulating your nervous system
to send those signals to your body that says,
hey, look to see if there's some work you can do.
And that's encouraging your body to fill in the gap
while you're away from your true-if-instruments
and while you need some extra boost
in addition to whatever else you're doing for Lyme.
In the same way,
if you're running the BX or the BY viruses,
you have to be using that in concert with something else.
Otherwise, your nervous system simply isn't going to recognize
what that signal is about.
Mike talked about the client
that had the pain issue in the shoulder.
The eye-resonant system is not going to fix trauma.
It's not going to heal wounds.
But it is interacting with the nervous system
where there's that pain response.
So if the pain response is just something
where the nerves got into a habit of being in pain,
that will help.
That's really what that's intended for.
I wanted to talk a little bit about how we developed those frequencies
and how we developed the MP3 files
because Mike was saying that if you're just generating a signal the whole time
and you're just fluctuating that signal,
you're always stimulating the straps or the pads.
So what we did was we used a hard limiter.
And we did that hard limiter in tiny, tiny fractions of a second
so that we were actually having signal and then not having signal
and then having signal so that we were mechanically producing
the pulse rate that is most efficient for the use with that frequency.
And that's actually how we're producing those files.
It takes about two hours for every second of file that we're generating.
Thankfully most of the time we get to a point where we can start to repeat
that frequency and that saves a lot of work for the rest of it.
When we were looking at the insect repellent,
the primary purpose for that,
even though it may work with other insects,
is we were concerned about the 80s Egyptian mosquito,
which you've probably heard on the news.
That's the mosquito that's believed to be the carrier for Zika in Chikungunya
and the things that are showing up as malaria in North America.
It's not the same thing as you're going to get with malaria overseas.
But if we could address that mosquito,
so we did some research,
found frequencies that were alleged to be noxious to mosquitoes,
found pulse rates that would amplify that noxious condition
and we constructed a frequency for it.
We put it on an MP3 player and it was actually my cell phone.
I went outside, I live in Florida, we have 80s Egyptian mosquitoes all over the place
and they're the mosquito that's going to come out during the day.
So I went out 11 o'clock in the morning and I had a swarm of mosquitoes
swarming around my bare legs,
biting me if they got the chance.
So I turned on my cell phone, played it through the speaker,
those mosquitoes could not possibly have carried any less.
They don't care about the frequency itself,
but I had the straps on, plugged them into the phone,
and immediately the mosquitoes started landing and taking off
and landing and taking off.
I had one after about 10 minutes that was so resolved to bite me
that it landed and its little provascus was poking around.
For about 10 seconds, it could not decide where to bite
and it finally flew off in frustration.
So when you run that, you're going to have mosquitoes swarming around you
but they won't bite you as long as that signal's in place
because that's being generated then through all of your skin
and somehow it messes up their nervous system,
they can't pick a good spot.